ميدانيا قالت سلطات المحليه الموليه
لروسيا في دونيتك ان المقاطعه تعرضت لقصف
اوكرانيا مركز اوقع اربعه قتلى وسبعه جرحه
واحسن هذه السلطات السقوط اكثر من 200 و
235 صاروخا وقذيفه اوكرانيه قالت انها
استهدفت ثم مناطق السكنيه ومنشات للبنيه
التحتيه خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه و
نشدت السلطاته سكانها البقاء في منازلهم
ودعتهم لابقاء مداخل الابنيه والمنازل
المفتوحه ما يسهل على المره الاختباء عند
حدوث اي قصف
دوري قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
اسقطت خمسه صواريخ من طراز هيمارس في دنيا
بالاضافه الى صاروخ اوراغان صواريخ
اطلقتها القوات الاوكرانيه في زاباروجيت
اضافت الوزاره الروسيه ان وحداتها صدات
هجمات اوكرانيه كانت تستهدف مواقع القوات
الروسيه جنوب دنيا
هجمات على مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه دونيتك مدعومه بسلاح حي الجو
والمدفعيه
كما تحدثت عن تدمير عشرات وحدات المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه
سلام خضر ومن كيف مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي
مرحبا بكما وابدا والسلام على مواقع هذه
الاخبار وكم الصواريخ التي يعلن عن سقوطها
واعتراض بعضها في دنيا صوره الوضع في
المقطعه
بين الجانب الروسي والاوكراني
اقل حده من ما كانت عليه الاوضاع يوم امس
الاحد اليوم استهدفت القوات الاوكرانيه
بحسب السلطات المحليه عدد من المناطق في
مقاطع وايضا في مدينه دانيت لكن لافتفت هو
ان احدى هذه الاستهدافات طالت اليوم ايضا
احدى محطات التزوج بالطاقه الكهربائيه
وهذا ما اضاف عبئا على سكان المدنيين في
مدينه دمياط هنا هناك احياء واسعه من
المدينه لا تزال دون مياه ودون غاز
للتدفئه ودون كهرباء اليوم بهذه الضربه
يبدو ان المعاناه للسكان المدنيين قد
توسعت السلطات المحليه هنا همم محمود
تحدثت قبل قليل عن ارتفاع اعداد القتلى
وصل الى اربع قتله خلال الساعات الماضيه
لكن السلطات ايضا تحدثت عن ما وصفته
احرازي تقدم عند خطوط الجبهات في منطقه
الدوم باس بشكل كامل اي عند همم في
مقاطعتين
دونيتسكو
الرئيس الموالي لروسيا قال ان التقدم في
بعض المناطق تم ب- بنحو 100 او 200 متر
ولكن في مناطق اخرى حيث القتال يسير بشكل
مباشر هذا التقدم لا يتعدى 10 الى 20 مترا
وربما هنا كان يشير الى ما يجري في باخمه
تحديدا جنوب باخم حيث القتال المباشر بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه مستمر
منذ عده ايام بشكل المكثف ولكن ضخمط
المدينه لا تزال بعهده الجيش الاوكراني
حتى الان ولم تستطيع القوات الروسيه
الدخول الى مدينه باخموس اشاره اخيره الى
انه صباح اليوم تحدثت سلطات ذا بولوجيا
الموليه لروسيا عن استهداف اوكراني
للمنطقه الصناعيه القريبه او هاجي على
محطه زبروجا للطاقه النوويه ولكن حتى الان
لم تقدم اي تفاصيل اضافيه عامر لافي في
كياف اذا اتصال بين بيدن وزنسكي ودعم
عسكري او عود بدعم عسكري متجدده ولكن ايضا
حديث عن صيغه سلام اوكرانيه ما هي هذه
الصيغه
بدايه الاوكرانيون هنا لديهم قناعه بانه
اذا ما بدات مفاوضات مع الرئيس همم الروسي
بوتن بدون ضمنات فهذا يعني انه هو يريد
كسب الوقت يريد تعويض الخسائر الكبيره
التينيا بها خلال هذه الحرب وبالتالي سيعد
لحمله جديده ضد اوكرانيا هذه القناه
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي هي تريد اوكرانيا
يعني تريد صيغه السلام الخاصه بها لكي
تكون لكي يكون هناك ضمانات مستقبليه اذا
ما بدات اي مفاوضات مع الجانب الروسي حتى
انا مستشار مدير مكتب الرئيس بالامس يعني
تحدث بشكل واضح وربما وصف هنا بينهم مبالغ
فيه نوعا ما عندما قال بان الطريق الوحيد
لانهاء هذه الحرب هو ان تهزم روسيا
ميدانيا على الارض وان تعذل
عن السوق العالميه وان تكون هناك خسائر
اقتصاديه كبيره بل وان يتم دعم
زمير الداخلي واستنزاف داخلي للاراضي
الروسيه اذا ما اراد العالم تحقيق السلام
هذا وفقا لمستشار مدير مكتب الرئيس لكن
طبعا الصيغه المتبناه بشكل رسمي وخصوصا
طبعا من الرئيس الاوكراني في ضميرنسكي هي
صيغه ال 10 نقاط التي كان قد طرحها في قمه
العشرين في الشهر الماضي والتي تتضمن عشر
نقاط كما ذكرنا هذه النقاط تعتمد بدايه
اهم النقاط الموجوده فيها هي ان يتم
المحافظه على سلامه ووحده اراضي اوكرانيا
اي ان تعود كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي
يصفها بالمحتله الى الاراضي الى الدوله
الاوكرانيه الامر الاخر هو ايقاف القصف
المستمر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه الافراج
عن السجناء والمعتقلين واسرى الحرب
الموجودين طالب بموضوع مهم كما يقول هو
العداله العداله
لمحاكمه ومحاسبه كل من 13 يدها بدام
الاوكرانين المدنيين الامر الاخر هناك
سلسله من الضمانات تريدها رانيا للضمانات
النوويه غير المحافظه على محطه محطات
الطاقه النوويه
الضمانات الغذائيه الضمانات ربما ايضا
الطاقه وبالتالي هذه كلها مجتمعه هي التي
تتبناها اوكرانيا في هذه الاونه ونذكر
طبعا ال سي بانزكي ربما في كل محادثاته
الهاتفيه في كل خطاباته الدوليه يتباد
اصبح يتبنى هذه النقاط العشره واليوم
عندما تحدث مع بيضه قال بانه شعر بالسعاده
الكبيره لانه هناك ردود ايجابيه سواء من
بيدن او بالامس من عند عندما تحدث مع
الرئيس الفرنسي ايضا ماكرون قال بان هناك
ردود ايجابيه نوع من التبني لهذا الموقف
الاوكراني لانه لان تكون هذه النقاط
العشره هي الوسيله للايقاف هذه الحرب شكرا
لكم
سلام خضر